what's the beef look it's weird to hate  someone because they're trans right but  it's also weird to love someone because  they're trans shouldn't you like them  based on who they are as a person  content of the character people are so  phony I love Caitlyn Jenner why she  sucks  she's against gay marriage ran over  person what's the good part  then they go well they have hard lives  all right well so the midgets  why don't you talk about how much you  like them where's that hashtag I don't  see any tweets about midgets who's got a  heart on a minute hard to get around  hard to drive hard to get work no love  and look I'm not anti-trans but I am  pro-mage